vectored Robo has been introduced in
android lollipop release for one year we
are getting many feedbacks that a good
chew is needed for the developers to
create access for vector drawable and
use them for older Android versions hi
this is thing--we from Android UI
toolkit team I'm happy to give you an
update on our latest to support to
address those concerns in Android studio
1.4 we introduced a new tool for you to
either easily pick one vector exit from
material design icon library or convert
your own SVG files into your wetted
robos moreover you can use this vector
access even when you are building
against pre lollipop release without any
code change that is very cool right
first let's dive into the new UI we
introduced in Android studio 1.4 if you
right click on any photos in your
application you will see one menu
options called Neill click that you will
see one submenu call vector exit click
that you will be able to see this new
vector access studio dialog assuming Y
now you just want to pick one existing
record exit from material design icon
library then you just click this choose
button then you will see a dialog with
all the X's in the library now simply
just pick one you like then hit OK now
you will see a nice preview for this
vector exit if you are happy with how it
looks then just go ahead and hit next
button otherwise there are some options
on the top right of this dialog for
example you can change its width and
height and you can modify the
translucency of the whole exit or add
Auto mirroring support for right to left
language
note that auto mirroring support is only
for version 21 and above in some other
cases if you just want to use your own
SVG files then please click this radio
button set local SVG file then you will
be able
to open a fire browser pick your own SVG
files they were then you will be able to
see the preview showing up given SVG is
a huge spec and often contains many
redundant information although we will
continue to improve our tool to support
more SVG file currently we don't support
all of the features in our tool yet if
we found anything in your SVG file that
we don't support we will be put it as an
error at the bottom please look into the
details of the error message and
simplify your SVG files and try to
import again or if you're happy with the
generated preview then feel free to go
to the next page you will see an SML
file with the preview showing up in your
web / drawable directory and you only
need to check in this simple SML file
into your code with procedural he
finished button now then the web to exit
will be successfully generated for you
now I will describe how the backward
compatibility works and its current
limitation first of all if your app is
targeted for lollipop or newer versions
then the full API spec is supported feel
free to modify and use the vector
drawable according to the spec however
we know many of you are developing on
older platforms in order to support
older platforms which don't have vector
drawable with some limitations I will
mention later our Gradle system would
generate a PNG SS automatically for you
here is how this automatically generated
SS looks like after you build an app if
you switch to the project view you will
notice there's a directory called pngs
under the generated directory under this
PNG
directory you will see familiar drawable
directories with different DPI's and
version numbers in simple cases you will
see a pair of directory for one
particular DPI
like here
one trip OS hdpi directory containing
the PNG file and correspondingly a
triple s hdpi version 21 directory which
containing a copy of the vector
drawables SML file this file structure
enabled abuse system to pick up the
vector drawable for SDK version 21 and
above while falling back to PNG files
for older versions there are some
limitations when we are dealing with
this backward compatibility support we
are trying our best to show the link
errors in the vector Jobos SML file for
this limitations first only a subset of
API features of vector drawable are
supported we are enhancing this now but
currently group and clip path tags are
not supported given we can only have one
static PNG files generated to replace
vector drawable in older Android
versions that also means in the SML file
of vector drawable we cannot support
dynamic attributes such as theming or
auto mirroring and for performance
concerns we don't support which sources
reference to other XML files second
currently the preview window inside
Android studio is using a display engine
which is different from the one using
the vector XS studio dialog and the
build process
why we are bridging the gap between
these two engines a good practice is use
vector access studio to import your exit
and keep the imported result then the
generated pngs will be always the same
as you see during the import process
last if you have to typecast the
drawable object in your java code be
aware of that on pre lollipop devices
this drawable should be casted as bitmap
drawable instead of a vector drawable
also set the drawable size properly to
make sure they show up correctly in the
older versions with all these tools
update
I want to thank all the people who
helped to get this to deliver and I hope
you find this is easier and more person
to use vectordrawable in your
application please follow us on more
update and improvements in the near
future thank you